- [Instructor] So we have a question here
from the 2015 AP Calculus AB test,
and it says consider the
curve given by the equation
y to the third minus x y is equal to two.
It can be shown that the
first derivative of y
with respect to x is equal to that.
So they solve that for us.
And then part c of it,
I skipped parts a and b
for the sake of this video.
Evaluate the second derivative
of y with respect to x
at the point on the curve
where x equal negative one
and y is equal to one.
So pause this video and
see if you can do that.
All right now let's do it together.
And so let me just first write
down the first derivative.
So dy, derivative of y,
with respect to x is equal to
y over
three y squared minus x.
Well if we're concerning ourselves
with the second derivative,
well then we wanna take the
derivative with respect to x
of both sides of this.
So let's just do that.
Do the derivative operator
on both sides right over here.
Now on the left hand side,
we of course are going to get
the second derivative of y,
with respect to x.
But what do we get on the right hand side?
And there's multiple
ways to approach this.
But for something like this,
the quotient rule probably
is the best way to tackle it.
I sometimes complain
about the quotient rule
saying hey, it's just a
variation of the product rule.
But it's actually quite
useful in something like this.
We just have to remind ourselves
that this is going to be equal to
the derivative of the numerator
with respect to x.
And so that's just going
to be derivative of y
with respect to x
times the denominator,
three y squared minus x
Minus the numerator, y,
times the derivative of the
denominator with respect to x.
Well, what's the derivative
of this denominator with respect to x?
Well the derivative of three
y squared with respect to x
that's going to be the
derivative of three y squared
with respect to y,
which is just going to be six y.
I'm just using the power rule there.
Times the derivative
of y with respect to x.
All I did just now is I
took the derivative of that
with respect to x.
Which is derivative of
that with respect to y
times the derivative
of y with respect to x.
Comes straight out of the chain rule.
Minus the derivative of
this with respect to x,
which is just going to be equal to one.
All of that over, remember,
we're in the middle of the
quotient rule right over here.
All of that over
the denominator squared.
All of that over three y
squared minus x, squared.
Now lucky for us,
they want us to evaluate this at a point,
as opposed to have to do a bunch
of algebraic simplification here.
So we can say,
when,
let me do it over here.
So when, I'll it right here.
When
x is equal to negative one,
and y is equal to one,
well first of all, what's the,
what's dy dx going to be?
The derivative of y with respect to x,
let me scroll down a little bit,
so we have a little bit more space.
The derivative of y with respect to x
is going to be equal to one
over three times one squared,
which is just three,
minus negative one.
So that's just going be plus one.
It's going to be equal to 1/4.
And so this whole expression over here,
so I can write the second
derivative of y with respect to x
is going to be equal to,
well we know that that's
going to be equal to 1/4.
1/4 times three times one squared,
which is just three,
minus negative one,
so plus one,
minus one,
so I'll just leave that minus out there,
times six times one,
times 1/4.
Let me just write it out.
Six, six times one
times 1/4
minus one
all of that over
let's see this is going to be
three times y squared,
y is one, so is just gonna be three,
three minus negative one,
so plus one,
squared.
Now what is this going to be?
And this is just
simplifying something here.
1/4 times four
that's going to simplify to one.
And let's see, this is
going to be 1 1/2 minus one
so that's going to be 1/2.
And then we're going to be
have all of that over 16.
And so this is going to be equal to,
we get a mini drum roll here,
this is going to be
equal to one minus 1/2,
which is equal to 1/2.
Over 16,
which is the same thing as one over 32.
And we are done.